[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
monde dans tous ses états ce soir notre
sujet d'intérêt c'est la thune le flouze
les pépettes pour parler d'argent le
vocabulaire est riche et plus que jamais
l'argent est omniprésent et hypnotique
en avoir un peu beaucoup à la folie
c'est une traque sans fin une quête sans
limite de new york à pékin en passant
par moscou c'est ainsi que les hommes
vivent
alors comment en gagner toujours plus en
travaillant plus c'est bien vous allez
voir pas forcément
prenez des notes vous ne savez pas quoi
faire de votre argent est bien découvrez
comment certains américains font charité
de leurs richesses
on peut également visiter un château
allemand en plein coeur du texas faire
connaissance avec des milliardaires
rouge à pékin fréquenté le très très
mondain et très chic bal des débutantes
à londres et puisque l'argent n'a pas
d'odeur voyez comment même au vatican
règne le lucre et dans un monde plein de
trésors enfouis il ya peut-être un magot
planqué à 4000 mètres d'altitude chez
les incas sur la côte d'azur
la profession de concierge est un
privilège mais tout de suite direction
l'inde et symbole absolu du business
hollywood bien sûr et ses éternelles
bref de gloire et de fortune
los angeles bienvenue chez kitson une
des boutiques les plus tendances
ici les victimes de la mode viennent
chercher les jeans les plus branchés du
moment
déchirée recousu le summum du luxe
stitches seven for all mankind derrière
ses marques une fois sur deux des
français minimum 250 euros lot jean le
jackpot surtout pour ceux qui sont à la
tête de ce business comme par exemple
philippe naouri un de ces français qui
font le jeans aux états unis bonjour il
a 34 ans il vient d'acheter cette maison
à los angeles
voilà c'est là où j'habite à los feliz
c'est le nouveau quartier de hollywood
reste hollywood c'est le quartier qui
montre où tous les nouveaux designers
tous les nouveaux star habite
voilà je vous présente ma maison c'est
une maison d'architecte de 1958
postmoderne
c'est très en vogue ici en ce moment en
californie je collectionne tous les
meubles de designers comme ims le
corbusier un mode de vie dignes des
vedettes de cinéma au lard honda c'est
ma fiancée
frédéric et de marseille aussi c'est la
coiffeuse des stars elle elle vient
souvent coiffée randa et d'autres stars
quoique julia roberts
coiffe aussi angelina jolie elle
travaille en berry dans un salon qui
s'appelle privé ça c'est la belle vie
pour vous aussi
ouais ça va on est bien installé on à
madonna qu'habitant o'keefe rct relents
de cabine sur le côté gauche
une maison brève et si philippe en est
aujourd'hui le propriétaire c'est qu'il
a mis la bonne idée sur laquelle il a
tout misé c'est le vintage ou comment
faire ressembler du 9a de l'ancien à sa
disposition ce gigantesque atelier un
laboratoire où il crée ses prototypes
dépendants ils arrivent quand même angle
des feds à broderies et on les assemble
donc ça c'est parti à broder et quand ça
revient idée il est monté des fois on
change et des trucs au dernier moment en
rajoute comme là on a rajouté avenches
et des stocks des pierres et puis ça va
arriver à un résultat comme ça
les intérêts jean rare c'est jean qui
paye combien ça vaut 310 dollars en
magasins
on a quasiment réinventé le marché du
jean le concept du jean
son astuce ajoutez des broderies ou
encore des petites perles sur des jeans
délavés faire en sorte que chaque
vêtement devienne une pièce unique faire
passer le prêt-à-porter pour de la haute
couture en tout cas redonné ses lettres
de noblesse aux jeans américain et ça
marche
leur griffe est aujourd'hui cotée en
bourse nous on paie la pauvre et 45
millions de dollars
et si ce petit miracle est aujourd'hui
réalité c'est grâce à un homme
il s'appelle paul ghz un milliardaire
qui ne se déplace qu'en jet privé comme
aujourd'hui où il quitte los angeles
pour las vegas et son salon mondial du
jeans haut de gamme et si sa fortune
bien du jean et bien aujourd'hui son
truc c'est plutôt d'aider et de financer
de jeunes créateurs paul weiss dans le
milieu du textile on l'appelle le
parrain
mais je suis un entrepreneur un type qui
peut qu'à la vision qui est clair c'est
très clair pour moi nous ça marche ou ça
marche pas mais si ça va marcher je vais
le inventé au maximum la sauce si vos
traductions il a financièrement les
reins solides mais une seule chose lui
manque
mais sega
regardez
de toute façon dans le jet pas le temps
d'en fumer 1
m
las vegas un disneyland géant mais aussi
l'endroit idéal pour faire du business
le salon du jeans se tient dans un
hangar à l'intérieur même d'un des plus
beaux hôtels casinos de la ville paul
gaz est ici comme chez lui
tout le monde le connaît et tout le
monde le respecte
[Musique]
marc présenter
j'ai
m
avec la famille une dizaine et une 10e
qui veulent joindre la famille ça va
nous faire 20 dans le temps
et parmi les nouvelles marques de
l'écurie poliet celle de philippe
justement le petit marseillais commence
à se faire un nom et le parrain a pris
les deux tiers du capital de lama en
échange de leur association antique avec
céline gorie sa femme
visiblement le lancement est un succès
le stand est le plus visité du salon
première journée et déjà près d'un
million de dollars de jean écoulée mais
la plus grande fierté de paul guez c'est
une autre marque
et pourtant elle ne lui appartient pas
c'est la propriété de son fils dhani 28
ans
c'est une association
avec
je suis
les gens dehors et à
j'ai pas les personnes
qui a fait un deal avec un actif de
retournement
je prends parce que c'est mon fils d'eau
phénoménale l'associé de son fils et la
super star justin timberlake
il a déjà vendu plusieurs millions de
disques il a de l'argent à investir en
plus tout le monde le connaît clients
comme distributeur c'est un très bon
coup pour dany genk
j'apprécie vraiment toutes les
gentillesses que tu dit dans la presse
sur mon fils c'est vraiment mignon
il n'y a pas beaucoup de célébrités
comme toi qu'il soit aussi gentil
ensuite je voulais que tu le saches
alors même si la relève est déjà en
place paul guez espère bien continuer à
piloter la french connection monde des
encourage tous ces
design magnifique le français qui
veulent venir à los angelès ce sont les
bienvenus
s'ils ont besoin de parler à quelqu'un
qui veut me parler
[Musique]
plus mal a encore lui ne fabrique rien
ne produit rien mais il vend beaucoup et
pour dénicher ces petits trésors c'est à
paris que cameron silver a rendez vous
il se rend à drouot pour une vente aux
enchères de robes les plus grands
créateurs français
cameron
habile les stars d'hollywood aujourd'hui
il est venu faire son marché pense que
vous allez trouver votre bonheur
j'espère surtout un bon prix sur ses
mannequins un siècle de l'histoire de la
haute couture christian dior vous avez
ce alors on vous avait jacques fath
balance yaga jean charles de castelbajac
que ted lapidus il semiac et que j'adore
qui est un très très grand créateur
pierre balmain ça c'est dior par saint
laurent c'est superbe
elle date de 59 lui trouver où tous sont
des crayons de particulière qui nous
amène ou des successions pour vos rides
et de l'estimation de cette robe
dans les trois cas le trac 3000 ans 1000
euros
c'est pierre cornette de saint cyr
célèbre commissaire priseur qui dirige
la vente
[Musique]
et c'est parti de logiquement numéro un
alors le numéro 1 100 c 32 forme
trentaine coudray si on commence à 250 à
droite les 600 700 mhz et 700 cède 1,2
me au t1 cameron va dépenser près de
15000 euros pour l'achat d'une douzaine
de robes cette robe l'algérie va la
vendre
ce sera un miracle pourquoi elle est
vraiment particulière
selon moi il faut vraiment être très
belle pour la porter il faut que je
fasse attention
c'est propre pourrait ruiner la carrière
d'une actrice je sais ce que celle ci
ferait une parfaite robe de mariée
qu'elle est la robe la plus chère que
vous avez acheté celle ci je pense
cameron est désormais le nouveau
propriétaire de la robe dior héritage
d'une grand mère française
elle est vraiment exceptionnel je les
adore c'est une robe parfaite pour la
cérémonie des oscars vous l'avez payé
cher il m'a suffisamment 2800 euros
c'est le prix de ce petit bout de
patrimoine français
et le lendemain il de retour à los
angeles il y à 11 ans sur melrose avenue
cameron silver a créé sa boutique
et ce matin cameron va préparé une
petite sélection destinée à une jeune
actrice
au total cinq robes qui l'a achetée adro
bonjour bonjour ça va
jennifer morrison c'est l'une des
vedettes de la série dr house elle
cherche en compagnie ce styliste une
robe qu'elle souhaite porter lors d'une
soirée de gala
celle ci je ne sais pas ce que ça peut
donner à mon avis il n'a qu'une très
belle fille comme toi qui peut
l'apporter
celle ci est une robe de philippe venet
de la fin des années 60
oui elle est magnifique c'est une
christian dior haute couture aussi elle
est intéressante avec du volume et là
c'est la robe qu'il te faut c'est aussi
une fiction dior mais dessiné par une
sono rance c'est sublime
un petit détail les semeurs ajouter des
perles
oui je suis une fille toute simple
quelle robe exceptionnels comme un coup
de tonnerre
très cher mais combien dix mille 500
dollars c'est cher mais c'est trop bas
une histoire elle a été dessinée par
yves saint laurent
lors de son bref passage chez dior
j'adore déjà elle est magnifique
son histoire lui donne encore plus de
charme
salut ajoute 1 0 cela rajoute surtout
1-0 à son prix c'est génial je me sens
un peu parisienne il y a trois mois en
france cette robe été légué par une
grand-mère à ses petites filles
après avoir été vendue à drouot elle va
retrouver avec cette jeune actrice
l'éclat des grandes soirées et leur a
permis au passage à cameron silver
d'encaisser cinq mille euros de
bénéfices
hollywood kahn a apporté jet pour les
plus grandes stars du cinéma bien sûr
comme sharon stone quand la diva vient
sur la côte d'azur
elle a toujours une petite attention
pour ce jeune garçon il s'appelle john
hutton gré il a 25 ans parmi ses clients
sharon stone donc sarah ferguson boris
becker jonathan est concierge
mais un concierge d'un genre plutôt rare
en france le terme de concierge un autre
niveau est nouveau on connaît le
concierge d'un hôtel 4 étoiles
on connaît le concierge d'un immeuble
mais le concierge que vous pouvez
appeler 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
même si vous ne descendait pas dans un
hôtel est quelqu'un qui peut rendre des
services bien différent potron serge
c'est nouveau
le métier de jonathan exaucer les voeux
de ses riches clients même les plus
farfelus aujourd'hui il part tester un
hôtel dans l'arrière-pays cannois un
endroit prestigieux où il doit monter un
scénario car c'est pour une surprise un
de ses abonnés l'anglais qui payent plus
de 30000 euros par an pour s'assurer ses
services souhaite faire une demande en
mariage original
je sais pas encore comment on va faire
ça pour ça que c'est une visite et ses
deux dunks ou aménager un espace qu'elle
aura vu juste avant d'aller faire ses
soins etc en ressortant elle repasse par
le même espace qu'ils soient tous
transformés et où le mari soit là le
futur mari soit là pour cent sa demande
exactement mais l'organisation de la
demande en mariage va soudain passer au
second plan pour jonathan
oui marque un coup de fil va bouleverser
ses priorités
tu m'intrigues beaucoup le souhait de
son client doit être prise en compte sa
sur le champ ok j'y serai c'est un de
nos membres et dit ouais ça
hello je l'aï un peu de mystère je ne
veux pas me dire au téléphone il m'a dit
on se voit tout à l'heure sachant tout
cas que c'est très pressé c'est pour
dimanche
il m'a dit à temps pour être ajoutés
fait de maintenant jusqu'à dimanche
donc voilà il résume chamboulé encore
mon agenda mais c'est le jeu c'est
marrant et une demi heure plus tard
jonathan arrive donc dans l'un des
palaces de cannes c'est ici qu'il
retrouve marc son client pour en savoir
plus sur le service qu'il doit lui
rendre
marc paye 35 mille euros par an les
services de jonathan mais marque n'est
qu'un intermédiaire le service n'est pas
pour lui c'est pour son patron un
milliardaire russe un habitué des
demandes singulière et surtout urgent d'
jonathan en perd même son sourire alors
il me faut une maison au maroc ouais sur
un atlantique 2 conférences sur la fin
c'est quoi donc que soit sa où ira avec
une plage privée sait pour combien de
pas écouté et lu plein entre amis c'est
pas pour lui non c'est pas pour louer
mais ils veulent a visité dimanche et
veulent a visité dimanche c'est à dire
que dimanche et en jet privé de venir là
bas et que tu lui montres déjà plusieurs
choses seles 3 jours pour jonathan
d'accord il veut que ça soit vraiment un
palais alors soit il m'a dit soit tu
trouves un truc qui est déjà une maison
qui est déjà en bonne état soit il s'en
fout il démolit tout il repense pas
d'accord bah de toute façon je pense que
si ça me dit je t'ai pas confirmé le
nombre de visites certain qu'il vienne
dimanche
j'imagine que yves pas que je trouve pas
ça
je l'envisagé pas ça devrait être le cas
si on en trouvera ces camps sur les
entourant ok bon sympa merci pour
jonathan pas une minute à perdre
il a donc trois jours pour dénicher la
villa alors direction tanger et pour
l'aider à trouver une maison les pieds
dans l'eau achetée pour le milliardaire
russe
eh bien il va faire appel à un agent
immobilier marocain hicham c'est mourad
le contact du concierge sur place qu'il
a appelée maurane connaît le pays comme
sa poche
ils ont trouvé une villa qui pourrait
convenir elle est à vendre et abandonné
depuis quelques années et surtout elle
donne directement sur la mer
[Musique]
une seule préoccupation pour jonathan
voir la plage privée avait pas sur l'eau
sur l'eau vous avez l'axé jusqu'à la mer
jusqu'à la plage mais très vite un
détail va être rédhibitoire pour
jonathan
il y a du monde sur cette plage c'est
pas de le déranger
s'il avait dans l'idée d'avoir sa plage
privée à lui si il faut et c'est
peut-être le produira où vous êtes dans
une crique où il ya que quelques maisons
difficile d'accès avec une plage qui
appartient à tout le monde mais qui
n'est jamais visité sauf par les gens
qui attendent notre ça ça serait l'idéal
un vrai petit bijou il espère donc le
trouver à quelques kilomètres de là
hicham l'agent immobilier marocain a
peut-être déniché la perle rare un
terrain directement sur une plage isolée
jonathan un peu de mal à le croire et il
ya quoi entre lui et la mère rien il ya
une route rien il ya 150 mais combien il
ya de distance entre lien direct entre
le terrain et la plage directement somme
n'est pas ça tu vas devoir marcher
le temps presse mais la route semble
valoir la peine le paysage devient
paradisiaque la mer et le sable fin des
arbres la petite forêt à part ces partis
de paris le terrain il va aller jusqu'où
le terrain ici jusqu'aux rivières
non mais acheter c'est formidable mais
là on lui construire un royaume
jonathan et enfin emballer les nymphes
hectares sont avant le terrain est
complètement isolé et ici tout reste à
faire
y compris construire la maison donc sa
maison il peut la mettre là jusqu'aux
courses ce qui est capable de faire des
investissements
vous pouvez tout faire
c'est agréable ces superbes vraiment
superbe
il aime ce qui est grandiose
spectaculaire il n'était pas content se
faire qu'on soit quelque chose là ils
démarrent 2 0 avec autant de places qui
veut il peut mélanger le côté je suis
seule au monde avec des dieux on dirait
compte dans le sahara il peut avoir un
quad des chevaux aller sur sa rivière
là-bas privé pour rejoindre la mer et
c'est un petit bateau devant
je pense qu'on a on a quelque chose
aux dernières nouvelles le client de
jonathan le milliardaire russe désire
acquérir le terrain pourrait bâtir son
palais on vient de le constater la bonne
idée c'est donc l'atout numéro 1 pour
faire fortune mais si vous n'avez pas
d'idées mieux vaut alors avoir un peu de
pétrole c'est le constat en tout cas
qu'on peut faire en ce moment même en
sibérie c'est la réserve d'or noir de
toute la russie
nous irons également en équateur à la
découverte de ces trésors ancestraux et
puis on fera également un tour au yémen
où vous allez le voir la nature pour peu
qu on la bichonne peut offrir des
richesse insoupçonnable à des milliers
de kilomètres de toute civilisation au
coeur de la sibérie des puits de pétrole
à perte de vue des conditions extrêmes
les deux tiers de la production de
pétrole de la russie concentrés ici dans
une région grande comme la france quand
il ment sikhs 1 million d'habitants
éparpillés dans la taïga et au milieu de
nulle part
la ville homonyme de cantine ainsi qu un
mirage tout droit sorti de l'imagination
post soviétique de l'ère poutine
c'est une ville modèle réservé à 80000
privilégiées c'est une grande et
merveilleuse ville
nous on adore ici il n'y a pas de
manifestation
pas de graffitis qu il n'y a pas de
toxico qui tue les gens avec des lames
de rasoir
notre solide et c'est de construire et
d'embellir notre région et c'est grâce à
l'argent du pétrole que tout cela est
possible des compagnies pétrolières
versent des normes taxe à la région
chaque année c'est une sorte de trésor
de guerre qui a fait de cantine chic la
région la plus riche du pays juste après
moscow c'est le gouverneur alexandre
filipenko qui règne sur ce pactole alors
on dit que c'est vous qui avez les clés
du coffre fort qu'on va faire contient
toutes ses richesses
il est bien écrit dans la constitution
russe
rezai le vrai détenteur de toutes ces
richesses c'est le peuple russe
un brin démago quand même le gouverneur
en fait le pétrole ne profite vraiment
cassé 80000 administrés grâce à l'or
noir
la ville offre des salaires deux fois
supérieur à la moyenne nationale des
primes à la naissance des soins médicaux
pour tous et un lycée proclamé le plus
beau de toute la russie par son
directeur alexandre b résine
ici c'est le jardin d'hiver
c'est là qu'ont lieu les concerts de
notre orchestre symphonique une ambiance
tropicale kitsch pour un lycée qui
bénéficie aussi d'une salle de
spectacles vide
la plupart du temps pour le directeur
c'est loin d'être une dépense inutile de
telles conditions permettent d'élever
une nouvelle génération de
l'intelligentsia et de l'élite russe une
ville idéale sans violence sans
corruption est uniquement réservé aux
plus riches
cette version fantasmée de la russie
demain pour suffit de parcourir 25 km
pour en découvrir l'envers du décor
cha cha 300 habitants n'est quelques
kilomètres trop loin qui pataugent dans
la boue
l'argent n'arrive jamais jusqu'ici
pourtant on voit bien qu ailleurs
certains se construisent de belle
baraque
de quoi tuer mais l'argent il est pas
pour nous qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
je vous dise de plus même son cloche
pour la femme d'igor son mari travaille
sept mois par an dans une concession
pétrolière perdu au milieu de la taille
et l'argent du pétrole mon mari il ne le
voit jamais même pas une queue de cerise
voix on y possède même pas notre propre
appartement
on n'a pas de confort moderne rien du
tout et lui il vit dans des wagons sans
électricité dans le froid ils ne gagnent
que 300 euros par mois et son salaire
est toujours versée avec trois mois de
retard au minimum naître au bon endroit
au bon moment
un impératif si l'on veut profiter de la
manne du pétrole dans la russie
d'aujourd'hui
mais le seul réserve parfois d'autres
surprises et cachent d'autres richesses
bienvenue en equateur sur les traces de
l'ancien empire inca philippe s noces et
français c'est un chasseur de trésors
s'affairaient attend maintenant 20 ans
que je fais des chasses aux trésors
retrouvés sous la mère j'en ai trouvé à
terre alors quand j'en trouve
normalement je vends pas les objets mais
quand j'ai besoin de psy je trouve
personne pour me pour m'aider j'en vends
pour pouvoir monsieur n'a jamais dépassé
la valeur une valeur tels disons que ça
permettait de le refaire d'autres
experts c'est tout à 61 ans philippe et
snos traîne derrière lui une longue vie
d'aventurier tour à tour chercheurs d'or
en amazonie capitaine au long cours sur
un trois mâts chasseur d'épaves
à 40 ans il abandonne tout pour une
nouvelle passion
il s'intéresse à l'époque précolombienne
et surtout de très près à un mythe
[Musique]
là je cherche le trésor et le data web
part il appartient au patrimoine de
l'humanité
je pourrais même pas profiter d'une
seule pièce ni pour amener chez moi ni
pour revendre les parts contre c'est un
challenge gigantesque et du carter en
egypte ça serait bien s'il y avait moi
ici voilà
[Musique]
atahualpa le dernier empereur inca au
16e siècle
il règne en maître sur la moitié de
l'amérique du sud quand l'espagnol
pizzaro débarque au nord de l'équateur
en 15 132 atahualpa et capturer pour
obtenir sa liberté il propose une rançon
les conquistadors reçoivent alors 5
tonne d'or et 11 tonnes d'argent mais
l'exécutif même commence alors la
légende
seule une moitié de la rançon aurait été
versée le reste n'a jamais été retrouvé
pour tenter de mettre la main sur le
trésor d'atahualpa comment philippe s no
s'y prend-il étape indispensable pour
ses recherches
les monastères de quito la capitale de
l'équateur dans la bibliothèque et les
archives des dominicains d'équateur
c'est du pur aux archives les plus
anciennes qui est dans le pays
et c'est là en partie j'ai sorti tout un
tas de renseignements concernant toute
l'histoire de d'atahualpa est
aujourd'hui philippe en est sûr qu'il a
localisé le trésor ont des doutes en
attendant pendant la période où on fait
les investigations et à partir du moment
où on réduit ont réduit ont réduit la
zone jusqu'à ne plus vous fini par ne
plus avoir de doute effectivement moi
j'ai plus de doute la cfi
pour lui c'est quelque part au milieu de
la cordillère des andes à plus de 4000
mètres d'altitude que se trouve le
trésor d'atahualpa 4000 da
à cette altitude l'oxygène se fait plus
rare les efforts plus pénible mais il
faut continuer d'avancer
parmi les nuages
c'est le prix à payer pour espérer
approcher l'or des incas
[Musique]
après avoir gravi le sommet philippe et
snos continue seul sa route censée
porter cette fois ci car il tient à
garder le secret dans cette jungle se
cacherait un fabuleux trésor
une découverte pour laquelle philippe et
snos ne s'interdit rien comme par
exemple dynamite est carrément l'entrée
de la grotte où ils pensent trouver le
trésor de l'inca
déjà il soit faire péter
[Musique]
or mal de trucs ex à une fouille sauvage
en solitaire avec pour seul équipier
un autre français olivier godard oui je
te vois cinq sur cinq
[Applaudissements]
philippe et snos ressort des entrailles
de la montagne enfin c'est n'a pas pu
aller bien loin
bloqué par un nouvel obstacle
lord atahualpa reste introuvable pour
cette fois en tout cas philippe
reviendra d'ici quelques mois après la
saison des pluies
mais pour le moment il est temps pour
lui de retrouver sa femme et sa fille
qui habite bien ris
il est temps aussi de se refaire une
santé avant le prochain voyage qui n'est
jamais très loin
j'aurais très pas bandant jamais
même si on trouve le trésor presque
toute façon l'argent
on parler clairement sais c'est que
c'est qu'un moyen s'est pas vu de ses
moyens ça permet de le faire d'autres
trucs ça permet de prendre des billets
d'avion de se payer des des hôtels
pendant qu'on fait des recherches etc
c'est tout ça pc uniquement un moyen de
la retraite
est la retraite j'ai commencé à
apprendre à 20 ans quand j'ai commencé à
chercher des trésors
la chasse au trésor philippe et snos n'y
renoncera jamais tout simplement pour
continuer de réaliser à l'âge adulte ces
rêves d'enfants
au yémen les trésors c'est la nature qui
les offrent dans cette boutique des
hommes déguste différents nectar
d'exception comme ailleurs on goûterait
un bon vent mais ici il s'agit de miel
c'est le miel le plus connu c'est du
miel de jujubier qui vient de la vallée
du wadi doan c'est un miel qui coûte
très cher combien un kilo coûte 8000
rial
c'est à dire 50 $ las les prix peuvent
grimper encore bien plus lourd et le
miel le plus cher du monde c'est celui
ci
que dites-vous c'est le miel le plus
cher du monde on utilise pour guérir les
douleurs d'estomac
c'est très bon pour la santé un kilo au
coût de 100 $
ce miel coûte encore bien plus cher aux
émirats et à dubaï où il est exporté sa
source
une vallée au milieu du désert une
vallée perdue est pourtant connue dans
tout le monde arabe
le wadi douanes pour rejoindre ce jardin
d'éden
il faut parcourir pas moins de 600 km
c'est un long voyage que nous allons
entreprendre pour remonter aux origines
du nectar et découvrir ses vertus
réelles ou supposées le wadi douanes
c'est un canyon qui s'étire sur 150 km
mais c'est surtout la mecque du miel
dans tout le monde arabe
la vallée est parsemé de villages qui
sont accrochés sur des pitons rocheux à
leurs pieds des oasis d'acacias pour les
90000 apiculteurs du pays plusieurs fois
par an c'est la ruée vers le miel la
grande transhumance des abeilles comme
des milliers d'autres à mr s'apprête à
faire voyager ses abeilles
cette nuit il va déplacer des dizaines
de ruches plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'abeilles vont ainsi pouvoir
butiner les précieuses fleurs d'acacia
la jeune numéro que les russes car nous
allons les transporter dans un lieu qui
s'appelle al hajari nous disons
proposons là bas car la végétation est
meilleur
l'environnement est très beau et surtout
il ya des acacias
mais je vois là l'âge allume une mèche
pour repousser les abeilles à
l'intérieur de la ruche
on bouche les rues de cette manière et
elle reste dans l'obscurité
si elle était à la lumière du jour
les abeilles sortirait fait attention
vas-y doucement
il est 5h le lendemain matin à mr
profitent de l'obscurité pour prendre la
route direction al hajar in 30 km plus
loin
nous roulons très lentement pour ne pas
effrayer les abeilles ne pas casser les
ruches au moindre accident n'est pas
vrai tout plus que quelques kilomètres à
parcourir
on voit déjà les premières lueurs de
l'aube qui pointe au dessus des falaises
le temps presse
il faut impérativement arriver avant le
jour
le pick-up arrive enfin à destination
et voilà comme ça c'est bien là une
oasis de verdure au pied d'un village
fortifié
c'est ici qu'a maire va installer ses
abeilles pendant plusieurs semaines
accompagné de son fils ils vérifient
l'état de ses ruches soulagement tout
s'est bien passé pendant le trajet j'ai
choisi cet endroit parce que le cadre
est idéal
le coin est apprécié pour son climat
à l'est nous avons les acacias et à
l'ouest
je l'avalé sommes bien orientées par
rapport à la lumière du soleil on laisse
les ruches sur place entre 40 et 45
jours voire 48 jours s'il faut les
laisser davantage pour qu'elle soit bien
remplie on reste plus longtemps ça c'est
de l'acacia pour les abeilles
c'est la saison elles butinent les
fleurs entre six et sept semaines et ça
c'est du jujubier tu vois le jujubier ça
donne aussi un très bon miel l'unique le
numéro un
ça c'est le vrai jujubier ce qui donne
le vrai miel plus tard à mr retrouve
salem c'est un apiculteur lui aussi
amer vient faire des affaires et
discuter de la prochaine récolte chez
salem on boit du thé sucré et il y à un
autre cérémonial entre amis au yémen on
mâche du khat une plante aux effets très
relaxant ou grand père était apiculteurs
mon père aussi
moi je le suis à montaut c'est une
tradition
moi même j'ai quatre fils et l'un d'eux
est apiculteur
quant au miel il est auréolé d'un
immense prestige c'est un don dallas
pour nous le miel est un cadeau dont
nous sommes très fiers
c'est le plus beau présent que l'on
puisse offrir on n'en crois rien donné
et lorsque notre président s'est rendu
dans votre pays
il est venu avec du miel il en a offert
à jacques chirac
ce miel les hommes du wadi doan savent
tous qu'il vaut de l'or pour un maire la
saison de l'acacia bat son plein
tous les jours il inspecte ses ruches
éparpillés dans la vallée ses employés
ou ne s'éloigne jamais bien loin des
abeilles
pas de protection particulière pour ces
apiculteurs du bout du monde
tout juste un foulard autour de la tête
pour aller extraire le trésor d'amer les
premières galettes de l'année ça c'est
du miel d'acacia que nous venons juste
d'extraire là nous allons le déposer sur
un fil le miel sera récupérée en dessous
nous allons le mettre soit dans des
bidons soit dans des boîtes ou dans
d'autres récipients selon la qualité du
miel
et là c'est un miel d'acacia de première
qualité
ensuite ce miel et bien il va falloir le
vendre nous quittons le wadi doan
direction 100 kilomètres plus loin sur
le marché au miel talent catane
[Musique]
al qassam une bourgade poussiéreuse mais
surtout la plaque tournante du miel au
yémen ah merci rend aujourd'hui pour
écouler ses dernières récoltes
tous les matins des commerçants venus de
tous les pays du golfe à court pour se
procurer ce précieux nectar
on regarde on examine s'étendre et on
apprécie son goût de caramel au beurre
et cette touche légèrement épicé du
gibier
oui ça vient d'où dubois d'idole
il ya combien il n'a pas de prix je
propose avant se mettre d'accord sur le
prix
amer le commerçant ont recours à un
tiers un courtier
c'est lorsqu'il relâchera leurs mains
que la sphère sera conclu n'oublie pas
que tu es pas seul ici et encore de la
marge
26-27 passé si tu voyais d'où vient ce
miel tu aurais proposé beaucoup plus il
est déjà bien cher là non c'est pas
encore assez cher tu achètes à 35
j'achète ok on vend
voilà un compte je vais les chercher le
reste combien là je te donne 2000 et le
raid et le reste je te le donne tout à
l'heure
je suis satisfait de cette vente oui je
suis content de l'avoir vendu à ce prix
c'est un très bon miel il n'y en a pas
de meilleure qualité
aucun autre miel 120 euros au total pour
les deux bidons soit 10 euros le kilo
amer c'est que son miel sera parfois
revendus jusqu'à 20 fois plus cher mais
il ne se plaint pas houllier même les
salaires des apiculteurs sont beaucoup
plus élevés que la moyenne nationale
lors des abeilles fait les beaux jours
de ses hommes
on se retrouve dans un instant et on
vous révélera comment gagner beaucoup
d'argent en ayant recours à quelques
méthodes un poil contestable mais très
rémunératrice chantage détournement le
crime malheureusement paye toujours à
tout de suite et nous voici de retour
dans ce monde où décidément l'argent
reste une quête ultime
alors si vous n'avez pas d'idée encore
moins de pétrole tout reste possible en
n'hésitant pas par exemple à enfiler un
costume d'ecclésiastiques pour récupérer
des créances de mauvais payeurs ou
encore en réussissant comme au vatican à
obtenir de petits arrangements avec le
fisc il ya encore une autre possibilité
plus risqués encore le kidnapping comme
en colombie où cette activité éminemment
lucratives est en train de devenir
presque banal
quatre employés d'une entreprise
anglaise enlevé en tchétchénie le pdg de
la firme sanyo kidnappés au mexique un
ingénieur français en colombie un
américain toujours pour de l'argent on
parle officiellement de 2000 kidnapping
dans le monde chaque année chiffre
sous-évalué bien sûr car les enlèvements
sont souvent caché aux autorités
premières victimes les populations
locales mais pour les kidnappeurs les
employés des multinationales sont des
proies de choix alors les entreprises
s'organisent elles s'assurent contre
l'enlèvement et au poids même des
négociateurs pour marchander les rangs
sont aujourd'hui pour les ravisseurs
comme pour les compagnies d'assurance le
kidnapping contre rançon
c'est devenu un véritable business
américain expatrié en colombie tom hades
rose a été kidnappé par la guérilla des
farc la guérilla des farc demande plus
de 5 millions d'euros en échange de tom
c'est pour eux le prix d'un gringo mais
l'entreprise annonce qu'elle ne paiera
pas les abandonner
la famille va décider elle même
d'employer un négociateur dans cette
extraordinaire document amateur
les radios ont filmé ce que vous n'avez
jamais vu jusqu'à aujourd'hui une
négociation de l'intérieur seuls
contacts avec les ravisseurs
cet émetteur radio c'est suzanne
l'épousé de tom qui contre la volonté
l'entreprise a décidé de négocier pour
faire libérer son mari et ce sont ses
fils qui vont assister le négociateur un
certain david un anglais il était très
important pour nous parce qu'ils avaient
l'habitude de ça c'était leur vie il
avait traité des dizaines de kidnapping
la plupart du temps avec succès d'après
ce qu'on savait alors on se disait qu'en
les écoutant
il y aura un moyen de sortir de cette
histoire etc alors peut-être mon père
serait relâchée première règle ne jamais
rompre
une négociation il faut resté cordial
ouvert mes kidnappeurs sont les maîtres
ici les farc utilise des codes tom par
exemple l'otage et appelé l'immeuble
comment va l'immeuble l'immeuble est en
parfait état
ok écoute écoute nous avons quelque
chose pour toi on te propose en tout
cent cinquante mille euros
il faut qu'avant demain soir vous ayez à
disposition les 150000 euros
nous vous dirons où trouver une
photocopie du contrat et la photo de
l'immeuble qu'on vous a promis
[Musique]
ok demain on tiendra la somme à votre
disposition pour le paiement final et la
libération de tom tu confirmes vous avez
que l'immeuble est en danger si nous
avons l'impression qu'il y a quelque
chose de suspect ok ne t'inquiète pas tu
sais que la sécurité de l'immeuble est
prioritaire et donc votre sécurité c'est
notre sécurité aussi un négociateur ne
parle jamais directement un kidnappeur
ici c'est un ami colombien il est chargé
de s'adresser à la guérilla les
ravisseurs ne doivent en effet jamais
supposer la présence d'un expert ça
pourrait les énerver dans les rues de
cali en pleine nuit ce sont les enfants
de suzanne qui vont chercher les
instructions de la guérilla bien sûr
c'est très dangereux mais là encore le
négociateur ne peut pas se découvrir car
ils risquent d'être repéré nous sommes
devant un fast food
les farc ont déposé dans les toilettes
derrière le chasse d'eau une photo de
tom agglo dans le jargon de la
négociation on appelle ça une preuve de
vie un document capital à analyser avec
soin il est arrivé que des kidnappeurs
exige d'une rançon
alors que l'otage était déjà mort le
négociateur a exigé des farc tom
joignent une lettre à la photo et qu'ils
décrivent la première d'un quotidien
afin d'être bien sûr qu'il est au moins
envie
ce jour live j'ai une copie du journal
el país daté du mardi 23 mai regarde son
visage
la famille de tom a menacé l'entreprise
d'un procès cette dernière accepte donc
sous la contrainte de finalement donner
l'argent de la rançon
plus de cent cinquante mille euros en
monnaie colombienne il cache le tout
dans des palettes en attendant le
transport des liasses de billets
marchander par le négociateur avec
l'accord de la famille qui affronte un
autre principe de base
on ne doit jamais payer tout de suite
s'il avait demandé plus de 5 millions
d'euros en échange de mon père et même
si on avait pu réunir cette somme
la chose la plus stupide ça aurait été
de payer tout de suite parce que le
message que ça aurait envoyé aux gens
qu'ils détenaient mon père sait et il ya
sûrement plus d'argent à se faire
c'est venu trop facilement après
instruction de la guérilla les liasses
de billets dissimulés dans les voitures
vont finalement prendre la route des
montagnes que ce soit pour une
entreprise ou pour une famille
il n'y a pas des changes argent contre
otage on largue les billets à l'endroit
convenu puis on attend
et pour les gros la tante va durer 15
jours avant qu'un soir tom ne fasse son
apparition au domicile familial après 11
mois passés enchaîné dans la cordillère
des andes
il a été relâché en pleine montagne et
c'est à pied qu'il est rentré chez lui
épuisé tom a l'air d'avoir tenu
psychologiquement mais la famille n'est
pas au bout de ses surprises
pendant toute sa détention
thomas griffonné sur deux minuscules
bouts de papier toute l'histoire de son
kidnapping un journal de bord
la seule chose qu'il ait pu ramener de
son séjour en enfer sans aller jusqu au
kidnapping pour récupérer de l'argent
la solution c'est peut-être aussi le
déguisement c'est en tout cas l'idée de
cette agence de recouvrement situés en
espagne
ici on a troqué l'attaché-case pour la
robe de bure
bienvenue au monastère des impayés
depuis le milieu des années 90 les
espagnols vivent au dessus de leurs
moyens ici l'endettement des foyers est
l'un des plus élevés d'europe
alors pour faire rentrer l'argent les
sociétés de recouvrement ont dû faire
preuve d'imagination
certaines déguise leurs employés en
panthère rose ou comme ici en moine
l'entourage du mauvais payeurs
récalcitrants ignore que ce monsieur
doit de l'argent
alors quand nous débarquons shenley ou
laissons notre carte de visite aux
voisins ou concierges
ils entrent immédiatement contact avec
nous pour se débarrasser de nous une
fois pour toutes
ça y est c'est parti la chasse est
ouverte journée classique
quatre dossiers en attente un peu moins
de deux cent mille euros
une affaire rondement menée et le
monastère peut empocher jusqu'à 30% du
recouvrement de la dette
le parcours commence dans le campus de
madrid un haut responsable de
l'université doit 35000 euros à l'un de
ses fournisseurs
je voudrais parler à monsieur mais il va
venir vous avez une carte de visite
depuis que nous allons revenir demain
après demain et jusqu'à ce qu'ils paient
c'est légal ça la loi ce n'est pas mon
affaire mais celle de monsieur c'est lui
qui en a besoin qu'il est uni la loi il
me doit à 35000 euros secondes à faire
pour le monastère qui mise beaucoup sur
la honte des mauvais payeurs face à ces
moines de la créance
il doit être en train de suffoquer
le concierge sait qu'il doit de l'argent
alors quand ils vont se croiser ce
monsieur va se sentir très mal
il va avoir au retrait
ce sont des pratiques légales mais assez
borderline limite de la justice et de la
légalité
une franchise sans doute jamais la
frontière et quittera cette frontière
nous mêmes nous pensons nous mêmes les
limites parce que nous connaissons la
loi nous ne faisons jamais de menaces
jamais de pression des moines qui on le
voit n'ont pas fait voeu de pauvreté
puisque aujourd'hui le business du
recouvrement de créances est plus que
jamais à la mode de faux prêtre pour
ramener à la raison les mauvais payeurs
et de vrais prêtres qui bénéficient de
largesses d'hommes politiques bienvenue
au vatican le vatican qui accumule des
richesses colossales en or mais aussi en
biens immobiliers et qui a reçu il ya
dix ans un nouveau cadeau fiscal de la
part du gouvernement italien
tout a commencé avec le jubilé de l'an
2000 les pèlerins se pressent à rome
l'italie manque d'hôtels alors l'église
réagi avec l'aide de l'état le
transforme couvents et monastères en
structure d'accueil
officiellement il ne s'agit pas d'hôtel
mais de maisons de vacances pour les
pèlerins les prix ne devraient pas
dépasser les 50 euros
problème dix ans plus tard ces maisons
se sont multipliés et les hôteliers
parle aujourd'hui de concurrence
déloyale
ok pc michel daerden est décédé
aujourd'hui clientèle d'un niveau 3
étoiles préfère descendre dans ces
maisons de vacances religieux car elles
peuvent proposer des prix bien plus bas
grâce aux avantages fiscaux dont elle
bénéficie de passe cette situation crée
un dangereux déséquilibres du marché en
faveur des institutions religieuses des
hôtels qui ne disent pas leur nom pour
échapper au fisc
faux répond le vatican il ne s'agit pas
de tel mais de modeste structure
d'accueil construite autour d'un lieu de
prière
elles ne doivent pas être considérés
comme entité commerciale
alors pour en savoir plus nous sommes
allés vérifier place farnèse au coeur de
la rome historique
voici la congrégation des soeurs brigidi
qui tient une église et un couvent
bonjour je cherche un hôtel je suis
désolé nous sommes complets pour le
moment mais venez me voir fait le taux
de l'église sur le côté une porte
dérobée une soeur nous attend elle parle
anglais
vous n'avez pas réservé non non ne
savais pas qu'on pouvait le faire
ah je suis désolé nous sommes complets
mais si vous tournez la rue il y à
pleins d'établissements comme le nôtre
demandé la villa de la sainte immaculé
ils prennent des autres un peu plus loin
vous trouverez aussi la villa farnesina
la liste est longue
sur la seule ville de rome l'église
gérer 850 établissements transformer
ainsi en maison de vacances soit autant
que le nombre d'hôtels recensées dans la
ville
vous réservez vos chambres uniquement
aux religieux maintenant tout le monde
peut venir
alors vous êtes un hôtel oui bien sûr
pour voir à quoi ressemble cet hôtel
cacher nous demandons à visiter les
chambres
une fois la porte passée le doute n'est
plus permis il s'agit bien d'un hôtel
trois étoiles
une réception où rien ne manque des
tapis des meubles anciens canapé cossu
registre des réservations cartes
postales tout y est
les soeurs ont même pensé au
merchandising une poupée de sainte
brigitte est en vente et livrables chez
vous pour 10 euros
la religieuse nous sort même un dépliant
papier glacé ventes en quatre langues
les mérites de l'établissement mais nous
ne pouvons pas accéder aux chambres il y
en a au total 23 elles coûtent entre 105
et 250 euros la nuit un prix en dessous
de celui du marché mais qui reste bien
trop cher pour un pèlerins désargentés
carlo petrini et spécialiste de la
fiscalité hôtelière et depuis cinq ans
il tente de dénoncer les abus de
l'église à côte alors regardez ici vous
avez un exemple typique des
établissements religieux qui est en
réalité un hôtel déguiser un véritable
circuit d'hôtellerie parallèle avec tout
ce que cela comporte comme irrégularités
d'abord ils ne payent que la moitié des
charges ensuite les propriétés de
l'église sont exemptés de taxes
foncières même lorsqu elles pratiquent
des activités commerciales et enfin ils
peuvent compter sur un personnel
quasiment bénévoles avec coton davantage
ils peuvent facilement casser les prix
du marché
un affranchissement qui représente un
manque à gagner de plus de 2 milliards
d'euros par an pour l'état italien des
taxes inexistante mais aussi des
pratiques commerciales pas très
orthodoxe le business made in vatican m
contourner les règles comme en témoigne
cet ancien employé d'une pension gérée
par des religieux voici le couvent dans
lequel j'ai été gardien de nuit pendant
trois ans avant c'était un endroit
d'accueil assez modeste et pendant le
jubilé de l'an 2000 cela s'est
transformé en hôtel
regardez
installée de véritables réception avec
des soeurs qui travaille à l'accueil
elles font un travail d'auteur rire mais
comme elles font partie du couvent elle
ne touche pas de salaire
les indépendants comme moi on n'était
pas déclarée on nous payait au noir
comment vous facturier au client une
facture est rien on donnait juste un
reçu aux clients comme ça il n'y avait
aucune trace fiscale et reçus étaient
des bordereaux qu'ils ont achetés dans
des papeteries sur cette affaire nous
avons voulu entendre la version des
autorités vaticanes mais personne n'a
souhaité nous recevoir
il faut bien dire que la relation entre
l'état italien et le saint-siège est une
longue histoire jalonnée de cadeaux en
tout genre idée de génie ressources
naturelles ou magouilles ça y est enfin
vous avez décroché la timbale j'en suis
heureuse pour vous vous êtes devenu
immensément riche peut-être trop du coup
voici quelques idées bien utile pour
dépenser votre argent à grands coups de
millions ou encore pour faire en sorte
de ne pas en perdre en mariant utilement
votre chère descendance
quand on a de l'argent et qu'on ne veut
pas le perdre voici donc quelques sages
conseils rien que pour vous amis
fortunés
vous êtes déjà la tête d'une petite
fortune personnelle et vous souhaitez
que votre descendance puisse faire
fructifier le capital familial est bien
la meilleure des solutions s'est
fréquenté le gotha en organisant des
petites soirées chics entre gens bien
nés histoire d'éviter toute déconvenue
le plus célèbre de ses pinces fesses a
un nom c'est le bal des débutantes une
sorte de boom mondaine de plus en plus
mondialisé il pourra voir son carton
d'invitation à son nom la personne a
bichonné sans faute c'est elle elle
s'appelle ophélie renoir c'est elle qui
délivre le précieux sésame
les invitations elle les distribuer par
cooptation en fonction de la notoriété
des familles dans chaque pays et marie
qu'on l'écrive
mais mais
mais je dirais qu'il ya peu de
candidatures retenues vais y en a mais
la plupart du temps neuf fois sur dix
c'est moi qui vais les chercher
aujourd'hui elle est à londres est comme
souvent c'est la maman de la débutante
qui est la plus conquise par la
perspective du bal rita sherman est
d'origine indienne
elle a fait fortune grâce à internet
elle a été élue femme asiatique de
l'année par la presse britannique fait
libre venez au salon l étage vous avez
fait vos voyages
très bien merci et l'heureuse élue la
voici ria 18 ans depuis qu'elle a appris
qu'elle irait à paris une seule chose la
tracasse il faut vraiment prendre la
valse
tout le monde me pose cette question de
mettre la valse c'est l'homme qui mène
la danse
il est plus important que vous riche
c'est lui qui doit savoir je n'ai pas
envie de tout gâcher
la valse ça a l'air drôlement dur où on
verra bien c'est drôle tout les films
dit ça perdure j'ai un peu peur celle là
a l'air fabuleuse ophélie a également
apporté paris des photos d essayage de
la robe de ria dans les jardins du
palais royal
mais comme celle-là est belle c'est vrai
de nos jours c'est drôle c'est moderne
et en plus ces filles viennent du monde
entier
c'est très multiculturel et
multiethnique jp pour capter le moulin
peu d'indiens non mais alors que
l'assaut bal des débutants
je me sens unique à faire ça anne mais
je suis en train de tracer la voie aux
autres filles de la même origine
je suis impatient d'y être
à plusieurs milliers de kilomètres de là
près de moscou une autre débutant 2 se
prépare
et là aussi c'est par la mer cofely à
trouver la fille elle s'appelle cette
fois ci zoé 18 ans également
elle arrive directement de boston où
elle est étudiante ah oui désolé
qu'est-ce que tu es belle tu as fait bon
voyage machine très bon merci vraiment
très belle entre on vient prendre le
petit déjeuner avec moi à les enlève ton
manteau et on va prendre le petit
déjeuner ensemble
zhan à la mère de zoé partage sa vie
entre new york et moscou
douée elle est en pension elle ne se
voit pas souvent ça nice alors le lycée
ça va que ça va bien
qui a eu l'idée d'aller au bal je dois
avouer que c'est moi qui ai eu l'idée et
le mérite elle est si jeune si belle si
intelligent que j'ai pensé que sa place
était là bas en plus elle travaille très
bien en place une fois dans sa vie
tout le monde a le droit à son moment de
samedi vous voyez en cendrillon story
oui un peu mais c'est surtout la rose
c'est vraiment une robe de cendrieux
classe vous savez nous les femmes on
s'imagine tout en cendrillon
quand vous avez la chance de pouvoir
offrir un conte de fées à votre fille il
ne faut pas la laisser passer
pour offrir tout cela ces enfants jannah
doit vivre sous la protection permanente
de gardes du corps
elle a fait fortune dans l'immobilier
elle pèse aujourd'hui 120 millions de
dollars
il ya six mois elle a reçu des menaces
l'anru si on ne prend pas la jalousie
des concurrents à la légère
paris place de la concorde
c'est ce soir que se déroule le bal des
débutantes toutes les jeunes filles sont
enfin arrivées et avant la soirée tout
le monde se retrouve pour une petite
séance de maquillage ou rial indienne se
moque du lycée bcbg de zoé la rue ce que
moi mettons lycée pour filles ce n'est
pas mon truc sans expand mais j'ai aussi
des copains non mais c'est vrai que je
ne vois pas beaucoup de garçons de mon
âge pendant la semaine
mais bon en faisant un effort tuant
rencontre grand moncton
oui c'est un couvent non ce n'est pas un
coup non vraiment pas non ça n'est pas
un coup devant vous avez le sentiment
d'appartenir à une nouvelle aristocratie
n'y avais pas pensé mais maintenant vous
le dit mais quand je rentrerai à londres
en tout cas je retrouverai ma vie
normale mon mari je n'ai pas l'habitude
de tout ça
[Musique]
et ce soir toutes ces jeunes filles bien
née auront donc la chance de valser au
bras de cavaliers tout aussi fortunés
venus de partout dans le monde mais
réunis par la bannière de l'argent
[Musique]
pékin capitale de la chine
ici on vénère toujours une architecte de
la révolution prolétarienne bas au bord
pourtant depuis 30 ans mais avec
l'ouverture économique du pays il ya 15
ans le socialisme est définitivement
enterrée et le capitalisme s'impose du
haut de ses buildings les grosses
berlines allemandes remplace petit à
petit les vélos dans sa voiture avec
chauffeur
voici yao ming il a fait fortune dans
les télécommunications
nous sommes en pleine semaine
aujourd'hui il ne va pas au bureau il
s'accorde du temps ils profitent
direction le toit d'un des plus beaux
hôtels de la ville yao ming n'a pas
besoin de travailler pour vivre
alors ce matin pour lui ces tennis avec
deux professeurs particuliers
[Musique]
mais vous avez le temps de faire du
tennis
j'essaie de m'organiser que de garder du
temps pour faire du tennis ou le tessin
d'or
et vous n'avez pas trop de travail au
bureau ce fait six mois que je ne suis
plus allé au bureau
s
mis à part le tennis deux fois par
semaine yao ming passe le plus clair de
son temps à acheter des oeuvres d'art
nous le retrouvons dans son appartement
aux trente troisième étage d'un des plus
hauts buildings de pékin c'est ici
qu'ils entreposent tous ses achats des
artistes contemporains chinois qui
peuvent aujourd'hui exprimer leurs
sentiments vis-à-vis du régime maoïste
[Musique]
ce tableau est fait par un jeune artiste
contemporain chinois qui s'appelle rogne
ongles sont outre oui à tous ces
personnages ont une tête de cochon
regarder le livre rouge ou le ruban
rouge font référence à l'époque de la
révolution culturelle est en réalité il
veut dire que le cerveau des chinois de
l'époque ressembler à celui des cochons
tour d'ana à l'époque de mao il aurait
eu le droit de peindre ça lui aurait
coupé la tête des oeuvres souvent à plus
de cent mille euros
yao ming est tellement riche qu'il en
achètent à tour de bras et il en a
tellement qu'il ne peut pas profiter de
tout tout ce que vous voyez ici ce sont
des biens que j'ai achetés dans des
ventes aux enchères près mais après la
date et regardez je n'ai même plus de
place pour les exposants mais aussi par
là et est aujourd'hui sont 600 m² est
trop petit alors il va déménager dans la
banlieue de pékin une banlieue cossue au
milieu d'autres millionnaires
il a demandé à ses amis de le rejoindre
pour leur faire visiter le chantier de
sa future maison de poires accroché
des centaines de toiles car ce n'est pas
le chantier d'un immeuble d'une usine
d'un théâtre juste de sa ville à 1800
mètres carrés
[Musique]
c'est l'espèce de jeux des enfants
c'est sur deux étages oui pour jouer
comme ça je vais installer un toboggan
qui partira de l'aïe qui descendra comme
ça là c'est une autre salle à manger
c'est suffisant non c'est trop grand
c
ça
excusez moi il ya beaucoup de maisons
comme ça en chine
en très peu oui oui très peu du moins
j'en ai jamais vu
pour le moment en tout cas parce qu'un
promoteur lui même millionnaire a décidé
de s'attaquer au marché des nouveaux
riches
il a 36 ans et devant l'affluence de
pékinois fortunés il a décidé de les
loger ensemble dans un lotissement de
riches des châteaux individuel en fait
comme des maisons préfabriquées
[Musique]
voici notre projet en développement un
parc résidentiel gigantesque vous voyez
chacune de ces maisons fait en moyenne
1500 mètres carrés vous avez vu le style
principal est européen les maisons
surtout sont de facture plutôt français
voici le projet grandeur nature près de
l'aéroport 172 château pour
millionnaires se construisent les uns à
côté des autres
le promoteur nous fait l'article
certains sont déjà vendus il ya même un
château témoins pour les visites et des
gardes factice le plus petit fait 1500
mètres carrés il faut compter 2 à 10
millions d'euros
meublé
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le salon au
rez-de-chaussée le maître de maison un
salon privé à les tâches
c'est formidable comme on a déjà
l'impression d'être chez soi
et pourtant ce n'est pas très grand mais
comme ces décors et avec tellement de
finesse on se sent déjà comme à la
maison
regardez la chambre des maîtres de
voyez ce plafond extrêmement haut et
c'est bien supérieur à la norme
êtes vous fier quand vous regardez ce
que vous avez fait oui je suis fier
quand tout sera terminé ce sera
magnifique
je pense qu'on ne trouvera pas deuxième
part comme ça dans tous les cas avoir un
château c'est le rêve de tous
milliardaires à pékin comme aux états
unis d'ailleurs mais là attention tout
est dans le détail nous voici en plein
milieu du texas c'est le château de
falkenstein un morceau de bavière planté
au beau milieu des cactus ce château est
né de la volonté et de l'imagination
d'un homme terry young
à 56 ans patron d'une entreprise de
bâtiment est en train d'achever un rêve
d'enfant un rêve qui lui aura quand même
coûté 50 sa vie et 2 millions d'euros
mon père était dans l'armée de l'air
américaine et nous étions basé à
wiesbaden en allemagne et pendant les
week-ends mes parents m'emmenaient ma
soeur et moi visiter les châteaux en
europe
la première fois que j'ai visité un
château de louis ii de bavière
je devais avoir 7 ans vous avez à cet
âge c'est un précieuse je crois que ça a
marqué ma vie et quarante ans plus tard
fortune faite
terry retourne en allemagne avec sa
femme et là il découvre le dessin d'un
château commandé à l'époque par louis ii
de bavière mais jamais construit nous
avons essayé de reproduire aussi
fidèlement que possible le dessin
d'origine mais forcément certains
détails voulus par l'artiste sont
impossibles à construire comme les gares
oui les sculptures ça ne peut pas être
complètement fidèle à l'original
maintenant il faut qu'on s'attaque aux
détails comme les effets de dentelle sur
la pierre par exemple je pense que ça va
nous prendre encore deux ans falkenstein
avec ses tours ses dix mille mètres
carrés habitables et ses plafonds hauts
de sept mètres
et bien c'est aujourd'hui la plus grande
demeure en construction au texas et
notre salle d'arts avec ces armures ses
tapisseries et son indispensable table
des chevaliers bien sûr la plupart des
armes et armures sont des reproductions
fait aux états unis
kim la femme de terry se débrouille seul
pour entretenir le château aujourd'hui
on peut dire que la châtelaine texane a
vraiment de quoi s'occuper ce soir
falkenstein fait la nouvelle année le
buffet tard et ça m'a coûté une fortune
j'espère qu'il y en aura assez pour
faire quelque chose comme ça il faut
commencer avec un rêve j'ai beaucoup
rêvé de ce château
lorsqu'on s'est lancé dans ce projet je
me suis dit ça va être génial
ce sera comme construire une grande
maison avec des tours quand on faisait
des plans je disais tout le temps à mon
mari je veux que ce soit encore plus
grand et encore plus haut pour beaucoup
de texans l'europe et ses châteaux
représente un rêve inaccessible se
retrouvaient à festoyer dans une
réplique même grossière n'a pas les
romantiques et bien c'est presque aussi
bien que de visiter l'original
voilà la haine
comment tu va très bien tout le monde a
l'air en forme
tiens laisse moi te sens tu es mon ami
tom moore à ses bourreaux
quand on vous voir l'année dernière déjà
j'étais en uniforme
j'aime bien habillés en militaires ma
femme me dit que je les note parmi les
costumes d'époque que je ressemble à un
dictateur sud américain
mais si vous regardez bien les documents
sur louis 2 vous verrez qu'ils portent
un uniforme qui ressemble à celui ci
[Musique]
à femmes qu'einstein la fête bat son
plein bientôt minuit et la nouvelle
année
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour terry et son épouse le rêve
médiévale n'en est qu'à ses débuts
[Applaudissements]
et si vraiment vous avez beaucoup
beaucoup trop d'argent est un peu
mauvaise conscience également
et bien voici la solution pour redorer
son blason le charité business très très
à la mode aux états unis tellement
tendance qu'il existe aujourd'hui un
journal le chronicle of philanthropy un
bimensuel qui tire à cent mille
exemplaires
c'est une revue de référence pour les
donateurs et les collecteurs de fonds
stacy palmer on est la rédactrice en
chef en quelques années elle a réussi à
se rendre incontournable pour les
millionnaires donateurs on couvre toutes
les activités des organisations non
lucratives des oeuvres de charité qui
récolte des fonds comme des donateurs
qui donnent leur argent
on est comme le wall street journal qui
couvre le monde des affaires
les gens dont on parle peuvent aider
après une tempête diriger des centres
sociaux il dirige des universités et des
associations de protection de
l'environnement
tous ces noms vous avez l'habitude
d'entendre de l'armée du salut jusqu'à
l'université d'harvard plus beaucoup de
petites associations
ils sont tous nos lecteurs chaque année
son journal publie le hit parade des
donateurs c'est du dernier chic on vient
y chercher ce qui ne s'achètent pas dans
le commerce
la reconnaissance les donateurs adore et
danseuses paradoxe la plupart en tout
cas parce qu'ils ont envie d'être
récompensés pour leur générosité
voici le top 50 ça ne vous étonnera pas
un poignet c'est warren buffett
combien at il donné il a fait une
donation de presque toute sa fortune
à terme cela sera plus de 44 milliards
de dollars du journal des philanthropes
à la presse people
warren buffet est fait souvent la une à
81 ans
donner c'est une première et c'est une
priorité pour lui de quoi faire oublier
son profil de sorciers de la finance
pour la première fois le patron sans
scrupules de la firme berkshire hathaway
assurance vie et boursicotage ça fait
applaudir pour une oeuvre charitable
il n'a pas vraiment l'habitude c'est
plus sympathique que dans les réunions
de ma compagnie le temps est venu de
distribuer ce que j'ai été heureux
d'accumuler j'ai eu beaucoup de chance
je suis né aux états unis en 1930 et
j'ai multiplié mon argent par 40
c'est un peu comme si j'avais gagné à la
loterie et ses 44 milliards de dollars
c'est ici qu'il les a gagnés à wall
street
son passe temps favori faire des aller
retour en bourse pour engranger des
profits
coca cola ou d'american express et
parfois il fait des investissements en
totale contradiction avec ses
engagements charitable exemple dans son
rapport annuel
on trouve des actions petro china pour
un montant de 3,3 milliards de dollars
petro china
c'est l'une des principales compagnies
pétrolières chinoises petro china
finance le gouvernement soudanais au
darfour
un gouvernement responsable de la mort
de plusieurs milliers de personnes
et ça warren buffet tu n'en parles
jamais devant les caméras
en revanche elles sont omniprésentes
lorsqu'ils signent ces chèques dans son
habit de philanthropes ses 44 milliards
de dollars c'est lors d'une cérémonie en
grande pompe qui les a donnés l'an
dernier à la fondation de bill et
melinda gates
une fondation qui elle aussi pose
question car ces investissements sont
parfois
pion avec l'aide apportée sur le terrain
exemple au nigeria où d'un côté la
fondation sauf des milliers de vies en
finançant d'importantes campagnes
sanitaires et de l'autre elle investit
dans les plus grosses compagnies
pétrolières au monde
implantée à km des centres de soins des
firmes qui menacent parfois
l'environnement et la santé des
habitants des firmes qui brûlent le
pétrole là où viennent jouer les enfants
et qui augmente le risque de choléra de
polio et de rubéole
[Musique]
et c'est donc tout naturellement au
sujet de ses placements financiers que
nous
à la directrice de la fondation gates à
washington après cinq mois de
négociations
patty stone faille accepté de nous
rencontrer selon elle faire pression sur
ces compagnies et bien ce n'est pas du
tout du ressort de la fondation mais
comment vous vivez le fait d'avoir des
investissements dans des compagnies
liées au surendettement ont des
compagnies pétrolières qui sont nocives
pour l'environnement en afrique
votre fondation il n'est pas question
pour nous de faire pression auprès des
entreprises pour qu'elle se comporte
mieux c'est au gouvernement de faire ça
aux citoyens et même aux employés de ces
compagnies qui peuvent faire pression
pour que leurs compagnies se conduisent
de façon plus éthiques
on pense que ce n'est pas notre priorité
on se concentre plutôt sur des actions
de terrain pour améliorer les
comportements en général
vous pensez que vous ne pouvez pas
influencer ces compagnies par exemple
les grandes firmes pétrolières pour
tenter de stopper leurs dégâts il eut
beaucoup d'exemples où des pressions
d'actionnaires ont fait évoluer les
choses
on ne dit pas que cela ne marche pas on
dit juste que nous avons choisi de nous
focaliser sur des actions et bill gates
qu'en pense-t-il
nous avons réussi à l'approcher
presse harvard nous n'avions droit qu'à
une seule question rigueur lynch au pays
à propos de philanthropie pensez vous
qu'une fondation comme la vôtre d'être
impliqué dans des placements éthiques
auxquelles doivent juste se contenter de
faire le plus d'argent possible
nous avons une politique en matière
d'investissements
par exemple nous n'achetons pas d'action
de compagnies de tabac
je ne peux pas dire que le fait de
refuser d'investir
personnes savaient pas très efficace
parce qu'on n'a pas investi assez
d'argent pour pouvoir être influent
alors le business un rôle à jouer oui on
doit mettre en lumière les entreprises
qui participent aux bonnes actions pour
que les autres suivent dans la mesure du
possible
visiblement en matière d'investissement
il n'y a que la fumée de cigarette qui
le dérange aujourd'hui bill gates se
consacre entièrement à sa fondation il
est devenu le numéro 1 des philanthropes
une des plus grosses fortunes de la
planète qui est bien décidé à faire
notre bien sans être à une contradiction
près
et bien voilà on vient de passer une
heure et demie dans un monde d'argent de
fortune et de délires parfois vous
l'avez vu assez mégalo j'espère en tout
cas que vous avez apprécié le
dépaysement retour à la réalité je vous
donne rendez vous très prochainement
à bientôt salut et d'ici là n'oubliez
pas rester curieux
[Musique]